- All right, so imagine this.
You're creating a new
startup smartphone company.
Your goal, of course, is
to make it huge, right?
So you make your first phone,
you launch with a bang,
you've got a bunch of
enthusiasts on board,
and you're slowly starting
to grow this thing.
And it starts going well
in Europe and in India
and a few other Asian markets,
and, you know, things are starting to grow
and go quite nicely.
But you notice there's not a lot of pickup
in the United States for some reason.
Now, there's a few
reasons why this might be.
I mean, a lot of people already know
there's a surprisingly
high amount of people
who just walk into a carrier store
to buy their phones in the US,
so if you don't have
a deal with a carrier,
then things might not
go well for you there.
And this is a enthusiast-only thing.
They're selling them online,
so that's understandable.
But then you get to the stats,
and the stats say the iPhone
has somewhere around 50%
market share in the US,
which is higher than the global average,
and it is steadily
growing every single year.
And worst of all, 87%, that's not a typo,
87% of teenagers in the US have an iPhone.
And that honestly feels
like the most damning one
because that means they got them early.
Like, everyone knows about the walls
Apple builds up around their ecosystem
to try to keep people in
the iPhone walled garden.
But 87% of teenagers, that just means
that this is a lot of these
people's first phones.
These people will be iPhone
customers for life maybe.
Like, for a lot of them, their
friends all have iPhones,
and if they're gonna get their first phone
for the first time,
they don't really even consider anything
that isn't also an iPhone.
It's the only way to get
into all the group chats
with their friends.
It's the only way to get
in on all the inside jokes
and socializations that
happen after school
from the FaceTimes to the iMessages
and all the things that
are just iPhone only.
So it's a very baked-in thing.
It's a very US-centric thing for sure,
but it is everywhere.
So this is why, when I made
that "Blue Bubbles vs. Green
Bubbles: Explained!" video,
I had to put that disclaimer
in the beginning of the video,
but that's why half
the comments were like,
"Yeah, I live in the US,
and I see this everywhere.
There's iPhones everywhere,
and the pressure of the
iPhone is very real."
And then the other half
of the comments are like,
"This is the dumbest thing I've ever seen.
Why do people care so much
about which phone people use?
Just use WhatsApp. It's super easy."
And so that's why that dichotomy exists.
But, you know, you get the idea.
So you are that smartphone company.
You're in this position.
You're trying to break out in the US.
What do you do?
It's a real question,
and as some of you may have picked up
by the title and premise of this video,
it's a real company too.
It's Nothing.
This is a company that's made
their first two phones now,
they've got some accessories,
they're trying to break out,
and their options seem to
be just give up on the US
or maybe try to strike a carrier
deal and get in that way,
but it doesn't seem like it might work,
or just lean all the way in
and embrace the actual
heart of the question,
the number one problem, the
biggest asset of the other side.
And that's what they're doing.
So what Nothing has decided to do,
and they're announcing this today,
is they have built iMessage
into their Android phone,
kind of.
So they've announced a new
app that is gonna come out
and be exclusive to the
Nothing Phone 2 to start,
and it's called the Nothing Chats app.
And their goal with this is
to literally offer iMessage
also on their phone.
Now, how does this work,
you might be asking?
Great question. Glad you asked.
So I've got it here.
This is an app that's co-developed
with a company called Sunbird
who has been doing this for a little while
in a restricted beta.
You might've heard of it,
and there's also a couple of others
floating around like this.
And basically what it does
is it lets you sign into
it using an Apple ID.
So you can just sign
up for an Apple account
without any Apple products.
You sign up for an Apple ID,
and then you sign into the app,
and it will give you as many
iMessage features as possible
without actually having an iPhone.
So, okay, a couple of things about this.
One, this Nothing Chats
app, when you first sign in,
is pretty intuitive.
You go through the setup process
to create a Nothing account
and then connect your Apple ID.
So, like I said, you can make an Apple ID
even if you have no Apple products,
and then you sign in,
and then everything
just seems to work fine.
It's more or less looking
exactly like a skinned version
of the Sunbird beta app.
And so sure enough, when
you go to message an iPhone
or join any group chat that
has a bunch of iPhones in it,
things that would not work
with an Android phone before,
it basically starts off
by sending through a virtual contact card
asking to merge your contact info
with your Apple ID email address,
and then suddenly it all works,
and you're a blue bubble,
and you're texting people with iMessage
from your Android phone.
Also, high-quality media is working.
So you might have heard
of this issue already.
This is actually one of
my biggest annoyances,
but when you message an iPhone
with an Android phone or vice versa,
and you send, like, a video or a photo,
it's, like, super blurry
because it's been compressed a lot
to fit in the file size limits of MMS.
But now you actually get
that full-resolution
photo and video treatment
as if you're just two iPhones
talking to each other,
which is actually very convenient.
Typing indicators work
when another person has
been typing for a while,
and they're also working
on the reactions as well.
It's not in this beta
that I've been testing,
but they say they're gonna have that
around the end of this year.
But then number two,
they're saying that they're launching this
as an exclusive app for
the Nothing Phone 2,
so just this phone,
and I imagine future
Nothing phones as well,
to sort of give people that option
where if they were gonna buy a new phone,
and they really wanna be
in the iMessage group chats
and all the iMessage features,
and they could only buy an iPhone,
they'll at least also have
this phone as an option.
But then three, this is the big one,
and I cannot stress this enough,
this could lead to
enormous security issues.
Signing in with your Apple ID
onto a device that you don't own
is an enormous security issue,
and it's a huge risk to anyone using it.
Same thing is also true
about Beeper and the others.
Because the way this one works,
and I've confirmed this with Nothing,
is when you sign in with an Apple ID,
it's literally signing in on some Mac Mini
in a server farm somewhere,
and that Mac Mini will then
do all of the routing for you
to make this happen.
You will never see or actually
hold or use that Mac Mini.
Now, no one else is
supposed to be able to use
or see that Mac Mini
or your messages on it
because it's all encrypted,
but you are still logging
in with your own Apple ID
on someone else's computer.
I don't know how else to put that.
Like, that on its face
is a big enough risk
that many people will
never even wanna try this.
But hey, if you're Nothing,
well, maybe this is just
enough to be able to say,
"Hey, we're offering iMessage
on an Android phone."
Like, this is a young
and crazy enough company
that they're gonna try stuff like this,
so maybe people will consider
a Nothing phone in the US
instead of an iPhone
that everyone seems to
just choose by default.
I actually talked to Nothing about this
as I was testing it before
this is all going live,
and I actually asked Carl Pei straight up,
"What do you think Apple is
going to do or say about this
once they find out about it?"
Because as this video goes live,
Apple's finding out about this.
And his answer was,
"Honestly, probably nothing."
But just because there's a weird timeline
we're living in here in 2023
where Apple kind of can't
really retaliate publicly
because they've already been up
against so much antitrust pressure.
Everyone already knows
Apple is using iMessage
and its powers to keep people
from leaving the iPhone,
but if Apple now, like,
publicly acknowledges this
as a competitor in the space
that they've gotta shut
down or something like that,
it could sort of shine a light on it
in a way they don't actually want,
so they'll probably just
quietly sweep it under the rug
and maybe just point
out some security risks
involved with the whole thing.
But then, of course, the
other side of the coin
is if Apple cares so much about security,
then wouldn't they wanna support RCS
so that the millions of
messages that go back and forth
between Android phones
and iPhones every day
won't be unencrypted SMS?
But that's another story for another day.
But at the end of the
day, the real question is,
will it work?
Will this strategy of
offering some iMessage stuff
on their phone exclusively
actually work for Nothing
to break out in the US?
And the fact is there's a
non-zero number of people
who will be willing to try this,
to give themselves the
iMessage, the blue bubble life
while still using a different phone.
There's probably somebody
out there who's like,
"I might buy a Nothing phone,
but, also, all my friends have
iPhones, so I guess I can't."
And for them, this is real, it's great,
but there's a lot of baggage with that,
and it's sort of a weird
timeline we're living in now
that this is actually a possible
thing that could happen.
Let me know what your thoughts are
in the comment section below,
if you think this will work.
Thanks for watching.
Catch you guys in the next one. Peace.
(energetic music)